[MUSIC PLAYING]
REENA NADKARNI:
Welcome to SEC211.
My name is Reena Nadkarni.
I'm the product lead for
security and analytics
on G Suite.
Today, we are going to have with
us a couple of my colleagues.
Panos, as well as Mitch,
who are going to help us,
and then also a really cool
customer story with Joey.
So I am very excited
about this session.
Before we dive deep, let's
start by understanding
why this area is important
and why it matters.
Google recently did a study
with over 4,000 customers
that told us that security,
even today, across vendors
is a number one barrier
to moving to cloud,
to upgrading to the cloud.
And we also found out
that irrespective of geos,
consistently, security shows up
as one of the top three needs,
along with things
like reliability,
that they care about.
So that's why, for us,
security and privacy
is a huge area of focus.
But why is this
really so difficult?
First of all, companies are
rapidly moving to the cloud.
As you can imagine,
they're using more and more
applications and more devices.
I read some stat
somewhere that it
was about 1,400 services
per large company
that they're using.
So you can imagine
it's really hard
to manage all these services.
Secondly, there's
constant issues
with updating patches and
such with your legacy systems.
And then, the security
attacks are on the rise.
So if you combine all
of these together,
managing your environment
is really very challenging.
So today, we are
going to look at what
we are doing both in Chrome,
as well as in G Suite,
to help you manage this better.
Before we go down that path,
I want to call upon an expert.
Panos Mavrommatis is
an engineering director
at Google Cloud.
He runs the Google Cloud
Safe Browsing team,
and he has worked at
Google on identifying
phishing and malware
sites for over 13 years.
His papers on
phishing and malware
have over 2,000 citations.
So at Google, we just basically
call him an underachiever.
Panos?
PANOS MAVROMMATIS:
Thanks, Reena.
So as Reena mentioned, I'm
the engineering director
for Google Safe Browsing, which
is a group of teams at Google
that fights phishing and
malware across the web, email,
as well as our platforms.
I actually joined in
the Safe Browsing team
as an engineer in 2006,
so I was able to see
the threat landscape,
as well as our defenses,
evolve all those years.
So today, I am excited to share
some of those trends with you.
For over 10 years, and
for 10 years before that,
Google has been doing
one thing really well,
which is to crawl the web.
What our team does is crawl
the web looking for bad sites.
Here, we present how
many new malware sites
we detect each week
in the blue line,
and how many new
phishing sites we detect
each week in the red line.
And this goes back all
the way since 2009.
So first, the good news is
that exploit-based malware
has been dropping,
particularly since 2016.
The primary reason for that
has been the security work
that was done by
the awesome Chrome
team over the last decade
that made browsers really more
secure against exploits.
Features like automatic
updates and sound boxing
of the rendering
engine have basically
made these attacks
extremely hard.
I wish I could say the same for
phishing, but as you can see,
phishing has actually grown
compared to 10 years ago.
We still detect over 30,000
new phishing domains each week.
And actually, the previous graph
doesn't show the full picture.
The malware exploits
have dropped,
but malware is still
around and malware still
finds its way to users.
It just uses a different
method of delivery.
It asks the user to download
and run the file themselves.
Last year, we showed twice
as many download warnings
in Chrome as in 2016.
Even when we look at
software downloads
from Chrome enterprise
users, one half
of a percent of every
file download that
could be carrying an
application or other software
is flagged by Google Safe
Browsing every single day.
Talking about scale
and volume of attacks,
Gmail detects and
protects Google users
from over 100 million
phishing emails each day.
When we look back
at our defenses
against these threats
over the last 10 years,
we have learned a few lessons.
I'm sharing them today because
I think they can be helpful
if you're either building
your own defenses
or choosing a
platform to partner
with that comes with
those defenses built in.
The first lesson we learned
is that, very often,
the cost of defenses can be
disproportionately higher
than the cost of attacks.
You can imagine why
that's a problem.
To give you an example and
add some color to that,
evading a classifier
can be done very easily.
For example, you experiment,
change your email a few times.
Change the file a few times
until it's no longer detected
and goes through.
If, on the other hand,
you're on the defense side
and your job is to
build a classifier that
will be evasion-resistant
to every past
and every future attack
that has ever been created
and will be created, you
should not take that job.
It is an MP hard problem
proven by academia,
and anyone in the
industry will tell you
that, yes, that's not possible.
Plus, the more targeted the
attack is, the more expensive
it is to defend against it.
High-volume attacks,
they even though they
can reach a lot of
people, they actually
carry a very loud
signal with them,
which is like their volume.
So defenders can use volume
to prioritize and defend
against these attacks.
Low-volume attacks,
on the other side,
such as spear phishing
or targeted malware,
they tend to fly
under the radar.
And to build classifiers
that catch those
gets more and more expensive.
Machine learning is extremely
important in our industry,
specifically for security,
especially in this space.
It can make a big
difference in reducing,
for example, our time to react
to changes automatically.
This allows us to build the
most evasion-resistant engines
we can.
However, one thing that
we found to be true--
and we've been using
machine learning since 2008
to classify both phishing
and malware on the web--
is that we really need to
invest in the training data
quality, what we call
ground truth, which
is both the labels
and the data itself,
the freshness of the data.
All of that goes into
the model quality.
And so the lesson here
was that you really
need to invest in the ongoing
process of maintaining
the quality of the data.
90%, 95% of your effort will
go into that, as opposed
to picking the latest and
greatest ML algorithm.
User education or
employee training
is something that is common
and it can be useful.
It can reduce the likelihood
that a particular user
may click on a
particular phishing link.
In our experience, this
does not solve the problem.
If you think about how
training is delivered often
to employees, we send them
a very original email.
Then we ask them
to click on a link.
Then they go through some
kind of authentication dance
and they probably enter
their corporate password
on a site they've
never seen before only
to land on a page that tells
them never to click on emails
and never to enter their
corporate password on a site
they've never seen before.
And then it tries to
explain to them how
to pass URLs with their eyes.
So you need to find
the third slash
and then go back two dots,
sometimes three dots.
And then that's the
domain you're on.
And so URLs were
built for computers,
and even computers have
trouble parsing URLs sometimes.
How can we expect,
let's say, a nurse
that is finishing their
shift to be able to determine
if a phishing link is
coming from a trusted source
or if the domain
is actually valid?
In general, what we
found is that we're
working with very old
and open ecosystems.
The web, email, desktop
operating systems,
these have been so
incredibly successful.
Everyone uses them every
day because they were open.
So we need to do two things.
First, work with
these platforms.
We can't just dream of the
future and ignore the present.
But we also want to build the
platforms of the future that
have security built into them.
That's pretty much our
strategy in this space.
For building the best
and fastest reactive
and proactive detections
on the platforms
that our users are
on, our best hope
is to leverage our end-to-end
visibility for web and email,
as well as Google scale
to protect the platforms
our users are currently using.
Next, we want to build
the next generation
of platforms, which are actually
designed with security in mind.
I'll give a very
quick example of how
we leverage our visibility
to protect users
on the web and email.
Some Chrome users opt into
sharing security-related threat
data with Google.
When Chrome detects
something suspicious,
such as typing your
password on a website
that you've never
been before, Google
is able to quickly
classify these sites.
These could be brand
new phishing sites
that no one has
ever seen before.
If they are
confirmed, then we can
push that data to
Gmail and Gmail
will filter out emails that
contain those links before they
reach the user's inbox.
So to summarize, I've shared
the current threat landscape
from Google's unique
vantage point.
I've shared some of the lessons
we learned while building
defenses against them.
And how critical our
end-to-end visibility has been.
Now I want to pass
it back to Reena
to share how would G Suite
and Chrome take advantage
of these technologies, and
provide additional security
features to help you protect
your employees and your users.
REENA NADKARNI:
Thank you, Panos.
That was insightful.
With the advances in malware
and phishing detection,
we believe that a truly
cloud native solution,
like G Suite and
Chrome Enterprise,
can help you secure
your company better.
It can improve your
company's security posture.
We believe that
we also don't want
to force fit a solution
on our customers.
We want to be able to
meet them where they are.
So today, along with data
that Panos shared, and some
of the insights and
lessons learned,
I'm going to share with you
some of the defenses that we
have to help you in your
journey to the cloud.
A simple way to think about
our defenses in G Suite
is that we want them to
be proactive, intelligent,
compliant, and simple.
Let's dive deep into each
of these very quickly.
So proactive.
The admins that manage
these large corporations
are really busy, and
cybersecurity skills
are very hard to come by.
So what we want to try to
do is, without the admin
having to do anything at all,
we have proactive defenses
in place.
So things like
polymorphic malware,
things like being able
to detect ransomware
that Panos talked about.
We're very proud of our
record of security on Gmail.
When we think
about intelligence,
we really think about how to
bring better machine learning
insights to be able to show
you all of these alerts
together and easier in one spot.
Our Alert Center allows
admins to manage these alerts
in one spot and take
actions on these alerts.
Last year, we announced the
G Suite Security Center,
and I think it's useful to
dive into that for a second.
The G Suite Security
Center helps an admin
go from prevention,
detection, and remediation
of all of your security issues.
So first of all,
before you do anything,
like I said, in
one spot, you get
a complete view of your
organization's security
picture.
We also show you a single
page where we give you
all of G Suite's security
settings in one spot,
and we also show you
if you're deviating
from Google-recommended best
practices in those security
settings, so that's
really helpful.
And then, finally, we have the
security investigation tool
that allows you to quickly
remediate these incidences.
But what about compliance?
Google's practices and data
handling practices and such
are audited by third party
auditors across the globe.
So when you come
to Google, we want
to make sure that we are helping
you in your compliance journey.
So for example, the ISO 27001
is a really good example
of a difficult-to-get
certification.
So we are here.
We're helping you on
your compliance journey.
And then what commitments
do we make to our customers?
Let's be clear about those.
First of all, no ads.
Google does not use your data
in G Suite for ads purposes.
Your data does not get scanned
for ads purposes at all.
Secondly, you own your data.
So G Suite customers
can take their data
and leave it anytime
through take out.
Your apps are accessible,
so we have SLAs around that.
And finally, you can
delete your data.
You stay in control
of your own data.
So these are commitments that
we make to our customers.
And security is only as
useful-- all these tools that we
make available to you
are only as useful
as if people really
begin to use these tools.
And so we want to keep
the security tools really,
really simple for our admins.
A couple of quick
examples of that.
The first one is that
we have one console--
a single console from which you
can manage all of your admin
security and other--
including your devices--
altogether.
With this centralized
management console,
people tell us that I used to
use this other system before
and it had 14
different consoles.
And we really believe in keeping
things simple for the admins
because they're so overwhelmed
with this amount of data.
Along with our admin
console for G Suite,
we also get cloud identity
which allows you to bring
in identity from other parties.
And we have our mobile
device management solution,
which has seen a huge amount
of adoption with our customers
both for Android and for iOS,
a mobile device management.
One of my favorite
features of our MDM
is that it allows you to
do agentless monitoring
of devices.
So what that means is if
someone adds your G Suite
account to a device,
without them having
to download anything at all,
your account is protected
and you get access
to enforce a password
and to do an account wipe.
Not a full device wipe.
You don't want to be
deleting baby pictures off
of somebody's phone.
But you can do just a G
Suite account wipe off
of their phone the
minute they add a G Suite
account to the phone.
So that's a really
convenient, very simple way
to get control over
your corporate data.
Data regions.
So with our geo
disposed data centers,
G Suite actually--
most of our customers
don't want to
regionalize their data.
They enjoy the high
redundancy and latency
that G Suite provides.
However, some of our customers
are under certain regulations
for which they cannot have their
data leave EU or leave the US.
So for that, we
launched data regions.
Really simple, adaptable.
So if I create an account--
if I create a document
and I am based in EU,
and then I transfer the
ownership of that document
to, say, Panos, who
is based in the US,
automatically, the
data regions policy
will adapt to that
change in ownership.
This year, we are also
including things like backups
and new G Suite services
like forms and sites
in our data regions offering.
So I'm very excited about that.
There's many customers
that are using
both Chrome enterprise,
as well as G Suite,
to manage their corporate IT.
We have Veolia, we have
Whirlpool, and others.
But instead of showing you just
these logos, what I thought
would be a really good idea
is for you to hear firsthand,
from a customer, what
their journey was like.
So for that, I'm going
to call Joey Smith.
It's my great honor to
invite Joey on stage.
Joey's the Vice President and
Chief Information Security
Officer for Schnucks.
He was brought in to build
a more mature information
security program in the wake of
a very public and catastrophic
breach.
He's joining us all the way
from St. Louis, Missouri.
Joey, welcome.
JOEY J. SMITH: Yeah, as Reena
said, my name's Joey Smith.
I'm the Vice President and
Chief Information Security
Officer for Schnuck Markets.
And I've given this
particular presentation,
or a version of it, in a
number of different settings.
And I got to tell you,
this is the first time
I've ever done it
in a movie theater,
and you all look
very comfortable.
So what I want to
talk you through
is a bit about who Schnucks is.
I've met a lot of different
folks over the last two days,
and so far, no one's known
the company that I work for.
And to us, that just
means you're probably
not from the St. Louis area.
Because Schnucks is very
relevant and large in the St.
Louis area, but we
don't have any stores
on the east or west coast.
So let me go a bit
into who Schnucks is
and what it is that we're
doing and, ultimately,
what led us to our decision to
move G Suite, and now further,
as we explore what GCP can
do for us as a business.
But since I'm going to
talk about a public breach,
as Reena mentioned,
I do always--
my attorneys ask
that I open and just
let everyone know that
these opinions are mine.
They're not representative
of my employers.
This also accounts for an
employer I used to work for.
I used to work for
MasterCard, and they
used to also have me say
this anytime we go up
and talk about merchants or
any type of breach event.
So with that being
said, I somehow now
have the green light to
go give you guys a bit
of a behind-the-curtains view
of what happened to Schnucks
and how we ended up
responding to that.
So first off, let me talk
a bit about Schnuck Markets
and the industry that we're in
and the business that we do.
So Schnuck Markets has been
around for about 79 years now.
We're coming up on
our 80th anniversary.
We were founded
in 1939, and we're
a third-generation
family-owned grocery retailer.
We have, at this point-- as
of about six months ago--
we have now about 120
stores across the metro St.
Louis area and
surrounding states--
Missouri, Indiana, Iowa,
Wisconsin, and Illinois.
We employ over 15,000 teammates
across all those stores.
We also have pharmacies
in all of our stores.
We're actually the 48th largest
food retailer in North America,
and the country's 17th largest
privately-held grocery store.
More recently, we've launched
a Schnucks Rewards Program,
a mobile app where you
can now shop and get
points for all your
purchases, and then you
can cash those
points in for money
off of your current basket
that's going through.
That's been wildly successful,
and we are on track
in the first six to nine months
here to have over a million
of our customers
on that platform.
So now we're getting
more and more data
that we've never had before
about our customers-- what they
shop, where they shop,
what they're buying,
those types of things that we
can leverage tools like Google
Cloud Platform to draw some
very, very powerful insights
into how we can specifically
target those employees
and give them experiences
that they're asking for.
One of the things that
attracted me to Schnucks
was what it is that they do in
the communities that we serve.
So we're very proud.
We offer our customers what
we call an e-scripts program.
This is a program that you, as a
customer of Schnucks, can go in
and you can set which
local charity you
would like to donate a certain
percentage of your shop to.
So this allows our customers
to pick organizations
that are relevant to them.
For example, my wife and
I, we pick the school
that our kids go to just
down the road from us.
And so a certain percentage
of what we spend at Schnucks
goes directly into the
communities that we serve.
So it's not necessarily this
big giant corporate initiative,
where maybe the corporate
company has chosen United Way.
And while, as a customer,
I could choose United Way,
I would rather put that more
locally into my community.
So we're very proud that we
donate more than $2 million
annually to these
types of programs
across all of St. Louis and
regions that we operate in.
This is, again,
one of the things
that attracted me to Schnucks
because it's something that--
us giving back really helps us
understand and put our customer
first, which is very
important to us.
So as ingrained
into the community
as Schnucks is, and as everyone
that shops there can appreciate
that they know that
their money is going
to some non-for-profits
that they appreciate,
and while we're all over
the map in St. Louis,
and as local as we are, like
all of you in the audience,
we also maintain a
global security threat.
And let me take you back
through a bit of our history,
and really going back
to the year 2013.
This was the year
that Symantec named
the Year of the Mega Breach.
And I have some of
these numbers up here,
and I won't read them
out loud, but you
can see this is really the
year that breaches really
started to hockey stick.
Now you look at some
of these numbers
and compare them to
the numbers today,
and this is really nothing.
But this was the year that
information security was really
put on the map and chief
information security officers
and cyber security teams started
to get a lot more attention.
They weren't really in the
back of the bus anymore.
They were coming
to the forefront
because all this
stuff was happening.
And at this time, I was
working for MasterCard
and we were doing analytics
on breach merchants
because we were able
to see the fraud data,
and we could correlate
that to what we called
a common point of purchase.
And we could identify the
merchant that was ultimately
bleeding the credit card data--
merchants like Target and Home
Depot.
Well, this was actually
before Target and Home Depot,
but this was that year wherever
the hackers that were out
in world started to
recognize and realize
the vulnerabilities
of merchant systems,
and the lucrative nature of
that magnetic stripe data
that goes through those systems.
By March 2013, or I should
say, really in December 2012,
Schnucks fell victim to
one of these statistics.
And little did the company
know but in December of 2012,
a hacker had gained unauthorized
access to our systems,
put some malware on our
point of sale systems,
and began ciphering credit card
data out of our environment.
It was by March of 2013 that
there was an incredible amount
of media activity around this.
The media gives no favors to
merchants that are breached
and really loves to
throw them under the bus.
And it was one of those
catastrophic moments
in our company's history that
we weren't necessarily prepared
to respond to at the time.
So as I think back
again, I was--
St. Louis is a baseball town,
and the Cardinals just started.
And like all good
St. Louis folks,
I was sitting on
the couch one day
watching the St. Louis
Cardinals play a game.
It went to commercial break
and the first commercial
that popped up was the
CEO of Schnucks sitting
on a chair, suit and tie,
on the edge of tears,
literally taking
commercial time out
to apologize to the
entire city of St. Louis.
I'm sorry, St. Louis.
We lost your trust.
We are committed to
winning that trust back.
It was unbelievable.
You don't see that
type of stuff today.
So the picture I'm
trying to paint
is this was before
there was really
a playbook on how to respond
to these types of events.
So it was at this
time we were just
seeing this incredible
amount of negative publicity
in the news, constant front
page story of all the local St.
Louis networks running this.
We were running commercials
to apologize for this event
and we were absolutely
besides ourselves.
So as a consumer and just
a customer of Schnucks,
I was absolutely floored.
And particularly as somebody
in the information security
field who has been dedicating
their career towards risk
mitigation and things
of that nature,
I couldn't believe
the amount of press
that Schnucks was getting
around this event.
And again, I go back to
this was before Target
and this was before Home Depot.
And oh, my goodness, Equifax
puts all of these numbers
to shame.
But this was something that
really pushed the company
to the edge of, how are we going
to start to respond to this?
And one of the things
that was interesting to me
as I interviewed for the job
as their first-named Chief
Information Security Officer
was they made a declaration.
They told me, we are going
to look at this event
and we're not going
to let it define us.
We're going to allow this event
to become our finest hour.
We're going to learn
from this event and we're
going to use our learnings
to be able to go out
into the communities that
we serve and further--
like Google Next, for example--
and be able to tell
our story and talk to,
whether it's our customers
or other folks in the IT
and security field about what
we did and how we survived
and how we came out of this.
So let me tell you a
bit about that story
and, more specifically,
given the theme
of this conference, what we
ended up doing from a Google
perspective.
So around this time, I
ended up taking the job.
I began to deploy a risk and
threat-based security strategy
where we were no longer
just focusing on compliance
and making sure we were PCI
compliant or HIPAA compliant.
And we began to hire a team
and move people internally
to come over to my
group to really start
to identify threat and risk and
look at our security posture
through those lens.
At one point, maybe
about a year and a half
or so into my journey as the
Chief Information Security
Officer there, we
actually did have
an event where a
piece of ransomware
landed on one of our
internal servers.
And fortunately, because
of some of the security
controls that we had
been putting in place,
it didn't do anything.
Our security controls detected
it and it did not install.
However, it did
breach our perimeter.
It got in and it landed
on one of our servers.
Mike Kissel's on my team.
He's the senior manager of
endpoint and cloud security.
Mike came into my office that
day after we looked at that
and we kind of wiped
our brow and said,
thank god that that
didn't install.
Because had it
installed, it would
have encrypted all of our
unstructured data, which
is where our Microsoft
Exchange server sat
in that particular data center.
And he came up to
me and he asked
me this very serious question.
And this was the
question that was
a key moment in our
decision as we started
to look at different
ways to protect
our data and our customer data.
And he asked me this.
He said, are you
confident, Joey,
enough in this detection
and response strategy
that we've been deploying?
Are you confident enough
that you, right now, can
walk into our CEO's office--
Mr. Schnucks's
office-- and tell him
that if a ransomware
attack hit our exchange
server that he can fire you?
I was like, well,
absolutely not.
We just dodged this one bullet.
We were lucky that our
endpoint controls actually
detected that and stopped it.
So no, there'd be no
way that I can tell you
that I would be confident
enough to walk into his office
and say our exchange servers
can survive a ransomware attack.
There's no way.
And he goes, well
I can tell you how.
I said, well, let's
start talking.
So this is the beginning
of the introduction
of what Google can mean for
a retailer like Schnucks.
So we began to look at
Google, and we looked at it--
obviously, I was looking at it
through the lens of security.
And what do we
gain by moving some
of our more valuable
corporate assets and data--
unstructured data,
as well as email,
calendar, and those types of
things-- into Google Cloud?
Under the lens of
security and looking at,
what's their security
posture look like,
and what's the funding that they
give to their security teams,
and how do they do encryption?
Versus all those same
questions on my side.
And it was the
clear winner that I
can't put in the amount of
security budget or security
stack that a company
like Google can,
a company that's focused
more so on security
than a local,
privately-held retailer.
So after a lot of collaboration
with the different business
units and looking at it
through my lens and they
began to look at it through
the lens of collaboration,
how can we more effectively
run store operations and things
of that nature, all the
other senior leadership
team at Schnucks ended up making
the decision that G Suite was
the right move to go.
So I'm going to talk now--
and this is where I'll close--
on the three major
learnings that we have had--
and we've been on G Suite now
for right over two years--
and what it is that we learned
in this rollout and some
of the things that went well.
Actually, I'll be very honest,
some of the things that
didn't go so well.
And some of the things
that we never expected.
So first, let's see.
What went well for us?
We moved to Google, like
I said, two years ago.
And prior to doing
that, I talked
about some of the
other senior leaders
that we engaged in this move.
So it wasn't just another
thing from Joey's team
who's hearing the
word "yes" a lot.
Because we come off
of a breach, they're
going to let me spend the
money that we need to spend
to help mitigate that risk.
Let's get the weigh-in from some
of the other business units.
So we partnered with members
of IT infrastructure, store
operations, digital marketing,
legal, asset protection, HR
communication, my group
and information security,
and created a steering committee
around this initiative,
making sure that what
Google could offer
us could also help solve
problems and allow them
to operate the way that they're
used to and, potentially,
even more effectively.
We started a tech team.
We issued a very robust
training program around that.
One of the things that I
loved so much about Google
was literally overnight, once
we turned Google G Suite on,
I was able to roll out
two-factor authentication
within just a click of a
button to our end users.
It was absolutely amazing.
I can't talk about
the importance
of two-factor
authentication enough,
from a security perspective.
Google lets me, lets us, do
that absolutely seamlessly.
It was a beautiful
thing, particularly
when you look at some of
the other offerings of how
much they cost and how
much they cost to deploy.
Two-factor just being included
is impressive by Google.
I thank Google for
that, for sure.
The immediate
collaboration that we began
to see across the stores--
I tell this story of we had
a older lady, store manager.
And her job every Monday morning
was to take an Excel sheet
and put all of the PNLs
across all the stores
that were in her division.
So that's maybe like 25 stores.
So she would get her store and
then 24 other email attachments
of the same stupid Excel
file with their PNLs in it,
and she'd have to
open every single one,
Control-C their data.
Then go to the other one and
Control-V-- copy, paste, copy,
paste 24 other times--
into a master file.
Save it, attach it, send
it up the chain of command
to the division manager,
who would then look at it
and have all that data.
It was just
absolutely ridiculous
and it was a very
"Microsofty" way to do things.
Well, once we rolled
out Google G Suite,
it was one shared sheet
across that entire division.
They can now do them on
their mobile devices.
They can update.
And one of the coolest
quotes that I got back
from that group was that
now I can do this-- what
used to take me 20, 30, 40
minutes every Monday morning,
I can do in five minutes
on my phone on the sales
floor with my customers where
I need to be, not upstairs
off of the sales floor.
And the most beautiful
part of that story
was these weren't
technical teammates.
These are just
teammates that were
able to figure out
this collaboration tool
and start using it to
get some of the more
busywork-type stuff out of the
way in a collaborative format.
Moving on.
Here's some of the
things that failed.
I talked about two-factor.
So we are a proud union
employer in the St. Louis area.
The union does have
contracts about you're not
allowed to use anything
corporate on my personal cell
phone.
So while you could
probably argue--
I think us tech-minded people
in the crowd here today,
we could probably argue that
with Google Authenticator,
you're not actually
doing any corporate data.
We're not calling your
AT&T, your Verizon.
We're not charging you for
text messages given those.
But we couldn't
push out two-factor
to their personal
devices and that was OK.
So we were able to solve
that through the UB keys
that we talked about a bit
for anti-phishing and things
like that.
So we can still
have the two-factor,
but it wasn't as easy
and wasn't something
that we necessarily considered,
the union aspect of that.
Limited number of people that
can get into a shared inbox
has been a bit of
a challenge for us,
where in a general inbox in
Google, you can share it with--
I think it's like 20, 25 people.
Well, our stores have
sometimes over 100 teammates,
so basically, we're left
for the store managers
to pick their
favorite 25, and those
are the ones that have
access to that store inbox.
That's an easy fix,
something that we've
told Google about,
and very simple
for them to be able to up that.
We're just waiting
for that new release.
Let's see.
Executive admins are a
hard group to please.
So they schedule meetings
and it's different.
It's one of those things-- we
talk about change management.
Some of the things
that we did well
was working with
partners of ours
at Augusto to work through
this change management,
and how do we address that?
Make sure you pay attention
to your executive admins.
They are the direct line
to your C level employees,
and what they say is what your
C level employees believe.
And if they have a bad time
scheduling an appointment
because they're not
used to something, then
ultimately, this
incredible product
can get a negative connotation
and it's not always fair.
So we did learn that we need
to spend a lot more time
with our executive admins.
They're not necessarily
the most technical people.
They love to listen.
They love to partner with us.
But at the end of the day, they
are very difficult to please.
Also with training, we had a
really good training program.
We made it very simple using
the Google tools for people
to sign up.
We did video content.
We recorded the meetings.
We did a lot of the same
things we're seeing here
with the keynotes, where they
were either streamed live
or you could watch
the video later.
And then ultimately, just trying
to get people hungry enough
to go seek out that
training on their own
is also very difficult.
Things that we never expected.
It was surprisingly challenging.
I was mostly excited
about Google, obviously,
because of the
security wins that I
get from the two-factor to the
encryption, data in motion,
data at rest, data
out of my environment.
But it was a lot more
difficult to get our end
users excited about something
that, to them, was just
simply perceived as a new
calendar and email tool.
And I say time and
time again, whenever
I talk to our Schnuck
teammates, that we did not buy
Google for calendar or email.
I really, honestly,
don't care that much
about calendar or email.
Those things are relatively
commodity in my opinion.
It's all the other tools
that Google G Suite
offers us that empowers
us as employees
and empowers us as a business,
email and calendar being
part of that.
But it was amazingly challenging
to get past the mind of,
what does drive
mean and how can I
use Hangouts versus
sending an email?
What is collaboration
in Sheets, Docs, Slides,
and those types of things?
Really positive ROI on the
reduction of our spam filter
that used to sit in front
of our exchange environment.
I know we talked about it a
bit in this session about what
Google's doing in spam, and
it is, again, just lights-out
better than any of the
competition that we had seen.
And we did have a spam
provider that we had in front
of our change environment.
Once we moved to
Google G Suite, we
saw that that went quiet
because Google was already
taking care of it and we were
able to sever our relationship
with that spam
provider, saving us
a very, very significant amount
of money annually on that.
We just let Google take
care of the spam for us now.
Again, all included as part
of the G Suite package.
I talk about users' technical
knowledge or lack thereof.
That's not something
to underestimate.
To us, it's very easy.
You click the blue
button that says send,
and guess what it does?
It sends the email.
That's not always
as understandable
by some of our end users, and
we were literally coaching them
through some of what
were take for granted,
as technically-minded folks.
So there is a lot of lack
of technical knowledge,
and it probably is more rooted
in resistance to change,
where--
we've had funny stories where
people are very adamant.
They don't want to
get out of Excel,
so they won't go to Sheets.
And the reasons
that we're hearing
are just laughable,
where we heard--
we heard a lady
talk about, I don't
want to move to Sheets because
I don't trust the math.
We're like, well, 2 plus
2 still equals 4 in Sheets
just like it does in Excel.
So moving-- and help
moving that needle
from a technical perspective
is also something
that we didn't expect.
And I talk about Excel and how
deep our love for Excel goes.
And that's very true.
We have a deep spiderweb
network of Excel files,
and I imagine that probably
most of you in your businesses
do as well.
Google does a great
job of, in most cases,
transitioning those
Excel files to Sheets.
What we ask our end users is,
as you create new content,
create in G Suite and
move forward older stuff.
But we're moving
further and further away
from Excel as we're
trying to lessen
our dependency on Microsoft.
But it's definitely been
a challenge and something
that you should definitely keep
in mind as you consider moving
your business to G Suite.
So those are some
high-level things.
What went well, what failed,
and what we never expected.
This was a decision that we made
in a post-breach environment,
and Google G Suite has
been a fantastic decision,
from my perspective as the
information security officer,
to reduce risk, help
us with threats,
stop spam, stop
phishing attacks.
And it's been
something that I've
been very proud to help
lead that way at Schnucks.
And it's been one of those
differentiating tools
as we look to continue to
mitigate our attack service
and lessen our overall
security risk so
that those types of events that
we incurred in 2012 and 2013
never happen again for us.
So that's our story.
I appreciate you
guys listening to me.
Thank you, Google, for having
me out here to share that.
And Reena, I'll hand it back
over to you to close us out.
REENA NADKARNI: Thank you, Joey.
Our mission is to really
change and make work
better for as many
people as possible.
And so hearing
stories like what Joey
did with his company's
upgrading to G Suite
is really heartwarming to hear.
So thank you for
sharing that story.
I'm going to next run
through some quick launches,
what's new this year and
what we are launching.
And then Mitch is going
to show you a quick demo
and we'll close the
session out, OK?
So first in our set of launches
is Access Transparency.
The blog just went out, but
this is an exciting area for us.
As customers, even large
customers that, in some areas,
compete with Google
move to G Suite,
we want to make
sure that they're
fully comfortable with what
G Suite does and does not
do with their data.
We never access a customer's
data for anything other
than meeting our contractual
obligations to them.
Sometimes, for example,
when customers call us
for doing something
like technical support,
Googlers do need to look
at your data to help
you mitigate those issues.
But what we're launching
with Access Transparency
is that every single such
access will be logged
and you will be able
to file a ticket if you
have a question about why
someone accessed your data.
And this is industry leading, in
terms of how much transparency
we are giving you for every
single clear text access
by a human being at Google.
So that's Access
Transparency for you.
The next one is to collaborate
on your security journeys.
So what we have found is
that most large companies
have a team of admins
that work together.
So first of all, we're
giving them the ability
to create automated alerts,
to take actions-- remediative
actions on any kind of
alerts that they get.
And the second thing is
that when you work together
as a team of admins,
you may have--
the way they collaborate
together is very archaic,
and we're trying to build G
Suite-style collaboration--
the example that
George just gave--
even in the admin
security journeys.
So for example, I come in early
and I have an investigation
that I am looking at.
And then the next admin
comes in and they want
to be able to follow along.
I don't have to take screenshots
and then message them
to them or email them.
I can share the investigation
as a view-only investigation,
and the other admin
can follow along.
This is going to be a
game-changer for our admins
because no one's really thought
about their user journeys
in this way.
So I'm very excited about this.
We also want to provide simple
access anywhere you are.
So if you're seeing--
there's a theme here, right?
We want the data to be secure,
but we do not want security
to get in the way
of your employees
as they look to be
productive in their day job.
So context over access is
a huge win in this area.
What this allows you to do is
that every single access that
is required for your apps
or your infrastructure
is vetted specifically
for that access,
depending on where the person
is, what kind of device
they're using and
things like that.
There are many signals
that feed into it,
and so that context over access
is also launching in beta now.
And then, like I said
before, for Data Regions,
we are adding new products,
like forms and sites,
and we will allow you to
store both your primary data
and backups in the
place that you want.
With that, I'm going to call
Mitch Christow, my colleague,
to come and show you a demo
of some of these technologies.
Mitch?
MITCH CHRISTOW: Awesome.
Thank you, Reena.
Hello, everyone.
So with the increasing
complexities
that the corporate
environments are facing
and the ever-growing
list of threats,
our security professionals are
really more and more burdened.
So I want to show you a
couple of examples of products
and features that Google's
rolling out in order to provide
you with tools
that make it easier
to use, provide
scalability, and also offer
best practices on
the security front.
Can you switch,
please, the input?
Thank you.
All right, within the
Security Admin tool,
for example, you
have the ability now
to see all of your
security-related settings
on a single page as it pertains
to all of the G Suite settings.
So with that ease
of use, we give you
a very simple way of seeing
all of your security settings
in a single location,
and also follow along
to see what are the
recommendations that we provide
for you to improve
the security setup
or also give you the ability
to see that you've actually
set up all of the
security-related practices
that we recommend.
So depending on
the settings, you
have a very simple
and scalable way
to actually view
everything that's
going on within the
resources that you provide.
Again, this offers all the
administrators a single page
to see all of your settings,
save time, and centrally manage
all of your
security-related settings.
In addition to the
resource settings,
we also offer you the ability
to manage access via devices.
More and more people
bring their own devices
to the corporate
environment, and you
have to control all
of these devices
in a scalable and
easy-to-use fashion.
And what we provide there
is the ability to do agent
list mobile device management.
So if somebody shows up
and brings their device,
you have the ability-- and
I'm going to use here my own
personal device--
to connect, for example,
to corporate resources.
And automatically,
without me having
to install anything
on my device,
I show up within the
device management.
There is no software to push,
no approvals to perform.
And I now, as an
administrator, have the ability
to control that device remotely.
So again, offering
you the ease of use,
as well as scalability to
handle any kind of device setup
that your users may
actually bring to the table.
And here, you can enforce
all your policies,
as Reena said earlier, wipe
the data that is specifically
pertaining to G Suite, or
just disconnect the device
altogether.
But within our
environment, you also
have to control access
way beyond the perimeter
of your network.
So these days,
people access-- you
have corporate resources
in any kind of environment
inside of your
corporate network,
outside of your
again, with various devices.
And until now, there have
been very limited capabilities
on offering fine-grained
and easy-to-use controls
in those spaces.
So with that, I want
to introduce to you
a product that we currently
have in beta, which
is the Context Over Access that
allows you to manage how people
are accessing your G Suite
resources with varying
levels of control.
So as I said, the product
is currently in beta.
Some of you may already
be familiar with it.
But in this case, for
example, a person that
accesses a Drive resource, you
can enable Context Over Access.
And by providing
that capability,
you actually have
the features where
you can manage access
either by IP subnet device
policy or access level.
So depending on the
location of your users
or the devices that they use,
or the particular access control
that you have allocated
to them, they now
can see whether or not
that particular user has
actually access
inside of the network,
as well as outside
of the network.
OK.
So just in closing, with
these additional tools
that we provide, you
can see how we're
making it easier for you to
control your environment,
provide you a lot more
control, as well as
scale these features
with, essentially,
an always-on default protection.
Thank you.
REENA NADKARNI: So to summarize,
Google's strength and security
really comes from our scale.
Google carries 1/4 of the
internet's overall traffic.
With Android and Chrome, as
well as Google Cloud Platform,
we're able to see
more and hence, we're
able to build better
machine learning models.
We're able to better use the
scale to protect our customers.
We're very focused on
the admin user journeys
as they go from prevention,
detection, and remediation
of their security incidences.
And I'm very grateful for
Panos, Joey, and Mitch
to be here today.
We're all going to
be waiting here.
If you have any questions,
please come back to us
afterwards.
With that, thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]